You've implemented the main
activity wireframe, so
now we can move onto
the detail activity wireframe.
This is what it looks like.
We have the date, the high and
low temperatures, and
then additional weather information.
We also have the weather icon,
and the weather forecast.
And these line up horizontally.
Build up the layout XML for
this wire frame.
Then modify the detail fragments that
you can populate all this information,
including these new views.
While you're doing that, you might as
well move the detail fragment into its
own file, so
it's separate from the detail activity.
Before you get started, I want to point
out that this layout has the information
taking up a lot of vertical space.
If you rotate your device
into landscape mode, or
you have a smaller height device,.
Some of the content could get cut off.
So think about how you can make this
layout be vertically scrollable.
To show you what I mean,
I added a couple of more lines of
text at the bottom of the layout.
Then I made the content
vertically scrollable.
So you could see all the information.
So go ahead and
make that change to your layout as well.
When you're done with all these steps,
this is what the App should look like.
We don't care about
the visual details now.
We just want to make sure that
the functionality is hooked up, so
all the right information
is displayed on screen.
You can use the code snippets provided
below for helper functions and
strings that you're going to need.
And again, leaving a place
holder image is fine for now.